[Musique]
c'est très bon passeur traditionnels on
a parfois chez nous puis en servent
toujours comment on peut manger la
sagamité 10e journée de la sagamité ça
peut ressembler à d'autres blocs on
pourrait retrouver de l'amérique du sud
juste que jusqu'aux ados ça sera pas le
nom sagamité mais oui on va retrouvé
quand même des mélanges comme ça en fait
à faire imiter ce que c'est c'est comme
ces propos lizano bones et wind chef
cuisinière abénaquise a accepté de
cuisiner pour nous ce plat qui rendent
hommage aux trois soeurs et trois soeurs
c'est la courge le maïs et la récolte
pour son ensemble pour cent son énergie
ce que vous avez apporté si trop et puis
c'est quoi ce treuil aussi incertaine ce
trou oui alors la place truies
algonquine sont vraiment bien adaptée au
climat qu'on est ainsi puis une peau
sans grande constat est fait que c'est
ce qu'il ya c'est justement ça aussi qui
ont fait pousser à charbon autres
lysanne à partager son savoir culinaire
avec les étudiants de l'université de
sherbrooke le mali en leur faisant
goûter à la sagamité elle collabore
ainsi au projet de jardin école
ce jardin est loin d'être banale il vise
à mettre en valeur le mode de culture
autochtone des trois soeurs ce qu'on va
faire on va s'occuper du jardin on voit
vraiment ses skis et encore comestibles
bien sûr le professeur tristan landry et
son groupe d'étudiants prépare le jardin
pour l'hiver comme cette plante et à la
fin de la session année par 600 partent
en vacances sans m'occuper nécessaire à
l'abandon mais revenue puis avait des
mauvaises autres sa gauche par la droite
un jardin ils reconnaissent d'un jardin
benec nous on était un peuple
semi-nomade n'ai pas le temps de
s'occuper de ça comparativement aux
troyens qui était ce qu'était cet enfer
et qui en avait une fierté de s'occuper
de leur jardin jetons jardin qui
s'inspire de ce que faisait lisieux
rocroyen du saint-laurent et on connaît
ce qu'il faisait grâce aux descriptions
de jacques cartier et c'est un système
agraire qu'ils ont hérité des
autochtones d'amérique centrale les 300
c'est un système très ingénieux qui
permet de combiner plusieurs plans et
les avantages de chacune donc le maïs va
servir de tuteur ou haricots
le ricoh va fixer l'azoté qui
naturellement dans la dans le sol ce qui
va donner à manger aux autres plans puis
les cours je viens de compléter en
couvrant le sol de leurs larges feuilles
qui vont empêcher les autres plans les
mauvaises herbes d'avoir accès la
lumière ça va aussi conserver l'humidité
du sol
quand on a décidé de créer le jardin
ancestrale à l'université de sherbrooke
avait plusieurs motivations des
motivations de développer la conscience
environnementale des étudiants
c'est aussi l'idée de faire des ponts
avec les communautés autochtones qui ont
préservé ses savoirs
un seul repas par jour oui c'est hugh de
paquets de viande paquet de trucs très
très très très protéine est juste et ce
qui était le but aussi quelque part
c'est d'être capable de se garder en
forme pour le rsa journée ça on parle
des royés binson système beaucoup plus
végétarien qui s'est quand même bouillon
qui était plus à base de tournesol le
système et 3 saas complète aussi d'un
point de vue nutritionnel lyrique où on
apporte des protéines le maïs apporte
des acides aminés les courges également
ensemble avec en plus les produits de la
chasse et de la cueillette ça donnait un
régime alimentaire très intéressant et
très complet chez autochtones avaient
remarqué par minc a défini their
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas porté aucunement
le bouquet garni les ânes fait cuire les
trois légumes dans un bouillon qui aura
préalablement mijoter pendant deux
heures à feu doux avec les autres
gibiers c'est du caribou c'est c'est
dounia sauvé par vous même au niveau
d'inscriptions est intacte la femme sera
censé chasser non plus non parce que
dans le fond puisque c'est elle qui
donne la vie on ne peut la vie utilisent
d orascom cement n'utilise que rarement
genre et mais de survie à nous trois
heures il nous faut aussi qu ouais ça
c'est vous les avez fait tremper ses
sauces et des incroyables qu'aucun sans
tremper son cuistot bien colorer les
jeux c'est beaucoup plus de rein qu'est
ce qu'ils savaient et et des autres
boeufs
ça c'est du vent ici
oui pourquoi y est blanc comme ça puis
pourquoi lier au lardin pop corn pas
fini c'est qu'on dit les suivait parce
que dans le fond c'est cuit dans l'eau
sandri et pourquoi ce qui est blanc est
ce parce qu'ils étaient blanchis vous
pouvez suivre la roue chine annoncé dans
le fond c'est la sorte de maïs qui était
utilisé moi j'utilise un maïs blanc ça
m'a aidé un canadien qui était de maïs
comprenez qu'on appelle de maïs de
cannabis parce que ceux qui en avaient
en majorité sur le territoire et au goût
des jeux s'ils étaient polis suivi le
maïs il très différent ce maïs blanc
lors que le de couleur cournot alors
pratiquement post crise
j'aime bien ça ressemble un peu aux pois
chiches leur entame de textos dans la
sérénité
on peut aussi utiliser la plus connue
des courges la citrouille ou une autre
variété c'est un mélange de plein boom
le sens parce que le bouillon comme tel
est déjà très goûteux les trois ça
commence maintenant être utilisé par des
gens qui produisent des paniers bio
parce qu'ils s'aperçoivent que cette
façon synergique est très intéressante
lorsqu'on veut cultiver de façon
biologique et donc c'est un système vers
le caire ont tout avantage de se tourner
donc je dis les gars mythe qui signifie
on invite à partager
merci beaucoup de jeunes s'apaiser
[Musique]